FTX founder Sam bankman freed has been
released on 250 million dollars Bond
after his first court appearance in the
United States prosecutors allege the
30-year-old defrauded investors in his
cryptocurrency exchange out of billions
he is now under house arrest at his
parents home in California Lilia Luciano
was in the courtroom for yesterday's
hearing
fan of 24 hours Sam bankman freed was
whisked by federal agents in the Bahamas
to New York City where he faced a judge
and walked out of a federal courthouse
after posting bail on a 250 million
dollar bond which prosecutors believe is
one of the largest in U.S history
that Bond will be secured in part by the
equity embankment Freed's parents
California home where he will remain
under house arrest we continue to work
around the clock and we are far from
done prosecutors say bankment freed
swindled FTX customers out of billions
in deposits in order to enrich his hedge
fund Alameda research and himself
Michael Parker is a former Federal
prosecutor it was a bit of a classic
fraud case where cryptocurrency on
deposit with an exchange was being used
as alleged once again to fund
essentially this hedge fund on Wednesday
is bankman freed a weighted extradition
Federal prosecutors announced two of his
closest Associates his FTX co-founder
Gary Wang and his former girlfriend and
CEO of his hedge fund Alameda research
Caroline Ellison had pleaded guilty and
were cooperating with investigators
these first two guilty pleas are
potentially devastating to his case if
you have two people at this level that
are saying that he knew about it that
would be very difficult to overcome a
trial for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano